[Music]  britney Spears's las vegas show is  coming to an end  a source close to Brittany confirmed to  ET her Planet Hollywood piece of me show  is ending the singer's contract for her  residency with Caesars Entertainment  expires on December 31st of this year  Britney's manager Larry Rudolph told the  Las Vegas review-journal Friday they are  quote done with the show but that  doesn't mean Brit brixton in Las Vegas  is through he told the publication her  next move is undecided and the venue  quote could be conceivably anywhere the  35 year old performers lawyer teased her  next move could even take place at the  needle on top of the stratosphere in Las  Vegas and she may quote do the bungee  jump afterward  [Music]  you